oui on n'a pas pu trouver une panthère
rose c'est dommage mais on en a trouvé
une panthère mouchetés qui appartient à
monsieur le sourd qui qui ont l'habitude
de prêter de louer des animaux pour le
cinéma c'est d'une panthère magnifique
superbe et jacques legras la tenue en
laisse jacques legras la tenue en laisse
et voulant toujours vérifier la bonne
volonté des passants il a demandé à des
passants de lui garder sa panthère sous
prétexte qu'il doit rentrer chez un
commerçant et que vous savez aux deux
ans rentrait des connaissances avec des
animaux alors bien entendu pour que la
surprise la plus grande la panthère est
un peu caché sous un porche et puis pour
éviter aussi des attroupements des
curieux parce que j'avais beaucoup de
curieux quand on se promenait dans la
pente avec la panthère dans paris alors
voici donc tournés en caméra cachée vous
allez regarder maintenant la réaction
des passants à qui jacques legras
demande de lui garder ça pour faire le
plus difficile c'est la mise en place de
la panthère loin des regards curieux
bien entendu les propriétaires de la
panthère messieurs lesourd ont une
double less qui leur permet de retenir
la panthère si elle voulait bondir en
avant on ne sait jamais
monsieur ça vous ennuie pas une seconde
de tenir mon animal parce qu'il
n'accepte pas les animaux
j'allais pas deux minutes c'est parce
que c'est pour mon animal de me tenir
parce que je vais où je vais au bout des
rues ou pas reste l'art est l'amour
ça vous ennuie pas de tenir le monde
animal j'en ai pour deux minutes j'en ai
bien plus longtemps
oui c'est mon chien bien sûr non non oui
c'est un chat et quelques roches à
l'aise et sûrs que cette marque armani 4
en france
sur you can follow it as a service
monsieur parce qu'il n'accepte pas les
animaux là la pâtisserie j'en ai pour
deux minutes à jouer quand j'en ai pour
pondre d'accord pour deux minutes là
c'est parce qu'ils n'acceptent pas les
aliments du tourmalet non mais écoutez
je peux expliquer pas là monsieur je
peux vous demander un service s'il vous
plaît au niveau de deux minutes parce
qu'il n'accepte pas les animaux dans le
dans la pâtisserie
si vous voulez me dit un jour j'en ai
trop pour deux minutes ça va pas tarder
ou la serbie pas je n'ai pas pour très
longtemps
après la réaction des hommes voici celle
des femmes
madame je vous demander un service parce
que je suis allé à la pâtisserie là mais
il n'accepte pas les animaux ça vous
ennuie pas le garder deux minutes là
elle est très mignonne
j'en ai pour deux minutes pour aller
chercher il est très gentil
non mais dans le jouet diallo expliqué
lors de sa visite
c'était pour atteindre est plus proche
du cinéma mais j'en ai pour deux minutes
oui mais je sais juste qu'elle serait
juste à dire pour help est magnifique
elle est belle
ohlala et il n'accepte pas les animaux à
la pâtisserie ça vous ennuie pas de
jeanne et jean nipon j'en ai pour deux
des deux minutes ça vous ennuie pas je
vous explique que c'est pour la caméra
et je vous écris que s'est il passé pour
une émission de très gentil
elle est alors oui elle est adorable oui
c'est souboz
d'être elle est très mignonne vous savez
n'ont cessé pour l'émission disant au
revoir à la panthère échanges d'animal
histoire de voir si les passants ont
plus ou moins peur d'un petit animal
qu'est ce que tient jacques legrand
laisse vous avez bien vu c'est un rat
ce réseau nuirait pas de le garder parce
que je dois aller chez le à la
boulangerie et puis ils ne veulent pas
ils veulent pas d'animaux
non non pas ce que je fais juste là et
retour j'en ai géré ça serait en effet
garder mon tir alors beaucoup doubler
nos noms vous voulez pas regarder vous
voulez pas regarder vaugirard mais sinon
oui c'était pour antenne 2 vous saviez
pas l'oréal est ou doit il aurait il
serait resté pour une demie a pas du
tout non non non non et tous les
concepts du chapeau
j'ai eu il faut j'aille la leaf aux
jeunes comment à la pâtisserie mais ils
veulent pas d'animaux savions pas le
droit mais si ça vous ennuie pas de le
garder n'est pas prometteur au jour j'en
ai pour journée pour 5 10 minutes pas
plus
ça vous ennuie pas trop non ça ne vous
fait pas peur cette huile est très
mignon oui c'est à cette blague a cessé
pour la l'émission d'antenne 2 ou savez
moi je dis cinéma nous étions film et
pour ça je m'arrête je vous remercie de
leur fils
oui oui c'est bien on va voir ça je dis
jeudi prochain